Hi everyone.
Welcome to the October version of the q
and a.
Um,
hopefully all my technology will work.
It's amazing that it ever does.
Q and.
A.
Um,
hopefully all my,
apparently it is good.
So let me catch you up to date on some
news first.
That would be fun as far as I'm
concerned.
So the first thing I want to do is share
something with you and that's this.
So I got this in the mail yesterday from
Penguin UK,
from an editor,
nick skidmore,
who I've been working with for several
months.
And so this is the 50th anniversary
version of Alexander Solzhenitsyn's
Gulag archipelago in it's abridged form
one volume abridged form,
which he approved.
Um,
it's also published on the centenary
centenery of his birth and I was invited
to write a foreword to it,
which I completed and which seemed to
meet with dissatisfaction of the editors
and also soldier Knutson's family.
Um,
it's about
500 pages long,
which is much shorter than the original
book,
which was about 1800 pages.
And uh,
Solzhenitsyn's approve the abridgment.
I think I might've said that.
So it's a remarkable piece of literature
and history and arguably the most
influential historical document of the
20th century.
You could make that case.
And so it was really unbelievably,
it was an unbelievable privilege to be
asked to write the foreword.
And I hope that I did a credible job.
We'll see about that.
It's on sale as of November 1st now I've
also prepared a youtube video for it
where I've read the foreword and some of
the content of the book to provide
people with an introduction.
And I'm hoping that this will be
something approximating a literary
event.
So I invite you to pick up the book if
you'd like to and um,
and prepare to be
shocked to your core,
I suppose is the proper way of thinking
about it.
So there you go.
So that's that.
Next thing.
I was in New York the other day
yesterday,
literally finalizing what I hope is a
deal for my second book and perhaps
books after that,
but certainly for the second book,
which is tentatively entitled
12 more rules for life.
There you go.
Um,
originally there were 42 rules and
I haven't used them all up,
so there's plenty of reason for
continuing as far as I'm concerned and
I've written a bit of it and it seems to
be going well and I'm hoping that I can
do a better job with the second book.
That's the goal and that's what I
discussed with the editorial team is
that I want the next book to be
substantially better than the last one
was.
Hopefully I can manage that.
So that's well and good as well.
I'm hoping that I'd have that book done
by next September,
something approximating that maybe for
publication the following January.
Now I've got a year after that if I need
it depending on what happens this year.
But that's the plan.
And then I'm going to tell you a little
bit about what's happening
with me
over the next,
I suppose year really it,
I might as well tell you that maybe
your,
you'd be interested in knowing.
So the first thing is,
is that tonight I'm going with Tammy,
my wife,
who's been traveling with me this whole
time.
We've,
we've finished 85 cities in the tour so
far and they've gone really well.
I would say.
So we've spoken to about 250,000 people.
I've been traveling with Dave Rubin of
the Rubin report and that's been
entertaining.
He's very comical and has been a good
adjunct to add a bit of levity and also
a certain degree of seriousness,
so that's good.
So on Sunday I'm speaking in Dublin and
on the 23rd that's Tuesday on Oslo.
I'll just go through the cities.
You can look up the dates at Jordan,
Pete peterson.com forward slash events
if you want.
Manchester,
Oxford,
Glasgow,
Edinburgh,
Amsterdam,
Cambridge,
Helsinki,
Stockholm,
Copenhagen,
Birmingham,
Oswald,
Stockholm and Helsinki.
So that ends November 11th then I'm off
with Tammy to Spain and Portugal to talk
to book publishers there and then I'm
going to speak to the trilateral
commission in Slovenia in Lubyanka and
then we're going to Hawaii.
I have a talk in Hawaii in,
that's at the end of November,
then to New York.
Maybe I'm going to talk to doctor Oz
again.
That's not finalized,
but it seems probable than I'm going to
Washington to talk to some people there
and then to Florida for a bit of a break
from Canadian winter even though I won't
have experienced any of that so far this
year.
And um,
I have a speaking engagement there as
well.
And then in January,
possibly I'll be in California.
We've applied for a tech incubator in
California to further the development of
our educational software,
which is already at the prototype stage.
I don't know for sure that will be
accepted into the incubator and I don't
know for sure if we are accepted,
if that that's the route we're going
take because there are other options.
We're also working with a private school
consortium to test the software,
um,
as we develop it.
Because when you're developing a
product,
this is a good thing to know if you ever
do build something,
you want to build a product,
test it with your potential customers,
build it again because you've made all
sorts of mistakes,
test it with your customers and so on.
So,
and then after that going to Australia,
New Zealand,
probably to talk in about a dozen places
there and then back to Europe in March
and April.
And then I'm going to write nonstop,
I hope from May to September.
And then with any luck,
I'm going to start the biblical series
again with exodus.
And so that's that,
that's the plan.
So,
um,
it's exciting and daunting and all of
those things.
So,
um,
now you're up to date and hopefully that
was interesting.
I really am thrilled about this.
This is really something then Mitch,
really something.
So,
um,
and I'm,
I'm the soldier knits and family was
happy with the forward,
so that was really
positive and hopefully it'll bring a
whole new audience to the book.
That would be a good thing.
This is not something that we should
ever forget ever.
Okay.
So let's say,
let's go to some questions here.
Any advice for a young counselor as soon
to finish his degree?
What do you wish you knew as a young
therapist?
Well,
let's start with advice.
Um,
well one thing I would say is you could
go to my book list and read the books
that are there.
There's ad on my website,
there is a list of recommended books,
fiction,
nonfiction and the nonfiction is
categorized in different ways.
There's a psychotherapy section,
I would say read those books.
That's,
that would be helpful.
Those people,
young Freud,
Rogers,
I think there's something by Adler,
unreal and Borchez some of the
existentialists from the 1950s.
Um,
lot of neuroscientists types.
Very,
very smart people.
very useful to know what they had to
say.
So
then the next thing I would suggest,
and you've heard this from me before
perhaps,
is that it's almost impossible to
overestimate the degree to which merely
listening is helpful if you're a
counselor.
Lots of people have no one to listen to
have no one that will listen to them.
And that's a real problem because people
actually think by talking.
And so for many people who are isolated,
they have no one to talk to.
So that means they don't think,
and that means that their,
their thoughts aren't straight and
organized.
And you might think,
well why does that matter?
But the reason it matters is because the
best analogy I would say to two thoughts
is that the best way of conceptualizing
the structure of your thoughts is to can
consider it in the same manner that you
might consider a map and your map should
be organized and things should be in the
right place.
Because otherwise when you use the map
to navigate in the world,
you don't end up where you want to be
and you run into things that you don't
want to encounter.
And so it's actually necessary to get
your thoughts in order since they help
you simulate the world before you act in
it.
And so don't underestimate how important
it is just to listen.
And then you think,
well let's think about listening to,
so someone comes to you and they,
and they come to you because they have a
problem.
Now you don't know what their problem is
and neither do they.
All you know is that they have enough of
a problem to come and talk to you.
So then they might have a problem
because really terrible things have
happened to them and anyone with any
sense would have a problem.
And so then they have problems in lives
in,
in life say,
or they have the existential problems
don't really psychological problems,
even though it might be psychologically
a demanding to adapt to the real
problems.
You want to listen and you want to find
out,
well what exactly is the problem space
and how much of that is practical and
how much of it is psychological.
So the first issue is you don't know
what the problem is and you want to ask
a lot of questions to find out what it
is and,
and,
and also what it isn't.
Because often people will come in and
they're upset and they don't exactly
know why they're upset.
And they might be upset about a whole
bunch of things.
And it isn't until after they talk
through all the things they might be
upset about that they find out what
they're upset about and what they're
not.
So another reason to listen,
especially at this stage of problem
formulation is to help people decide
what their problems aren't.
Well then the next thing you have to do
to listen is like,
okay,
well now we,
we know what the problem is.
Well,
what would your client view as a
potential solution?
So assuming that this could be made
better in some manner,
what would better look like?
So you need to develop code,
develop a philosophy of what's better.
And so that's a goal or an aim and it's
almost like a personalized definition of
mental health.
But it might be better to think about it
as a personalized definition of,
um,
of a good life.
And so,
uh,
that's the next thing you have to listen
to about.
And then the last thing you have to
listen about and negotiated as well as,
okay,
well now we know what your problem is.
And we know hypothetically what the
destination is with regards to solving
that problem is what are the strategies
that are necessary to implement in order
to make that positive outcome ochre?
And then that's something that you
negotiate by listening every week.
It's like,
okay,
well here's the goal.
What steps could we take that you would
implement that would move you towards
that goal?
Can you take those steps in the world?
Will you do that this week?
And then watch whether or not you do it
and come back and report and also tell
me and yourself whether or not
implementing that actually worked.
And then we can come back and we can
have a discussion about whether you did
it or not.
And if you didn't,
then how we could modify that.
And if you did,
how we could continue and expanded.
And if you did do it,
whether it worked and if it,
if it and what unexpected things
occurred and what if any implications
there are for understanding problem and
for your goal.
And so you know you,
you need,
it's a map.
You have a starting point.
You have to figure out what that is.
You have a destination point,
the desired future.
You have to figure out what that is.
You have to implement and design
strategies that will move the person
forward.
And then you have to test all those
strategies.
Very strategic thinking,
very practical thinking.
And so,
um,
that's,
that's an outline of how to do effective
psychotherapy.
I would say effective,
careful psychotherapy.
And another bit of advice is people
often who are young counselors are
afraid and don't know how they can not
take their client's problems home.
And I've got a couple of things to say
about that.
The first is they're not your problems.
And it's very important to remember that
it's partly you don't want to steal your
client's problems.
I mean,
you might think,
well,
if I could take my client's problems on
myself and lift the burden from the
mall,
wouldn't that be better?
And the answer is,
well,
no,
because someone's problems are not that
distinguishable from their life.
And what you're there to do is
facilitate their ability to learn,
to grapple successfully with the
existential vagaries of their own
existence.
And you don't want to leap in there and
steal it.
Like let's say you give a spectacular
piece of advice and you're going to give
advice now and then,
but it's not that advisable.
Then let's say you advise someone to
solve a problem in a certain way and
they go do it.
And the problem solved.
It's like,
well,
the problems disappeared,
but they didn't learn how to generate
the solution to the problem.
And so they're in worst shape with
future problems and it's your victory in
some senses,
stead of theirs.
And so you don't want to,
you don't want to steal from your
clients destiny.
And so,
and that also frees you up to some
degree because it also means that you're
not morally obligated to take on those
problems and carry them home.
And the other thing is,
is that it doesn't do your client any
good for their problems to sink you.
You have a moral obligation,
an ethical obligation of professional
obligation to remain sufficiently
detached from the situation so that your
head is clear and you remain healthy
and,
and your practice remains viable for the
long run.
And so don't forget to protect yourself.
It's very,
very important.
Let let your clients sort out their
lives.
You're there to help.
You're there as a sounding board year.
There is a strategic,
uh,
you're there to offer strategic advice.
You're there to shed light on the
symptomatology and to lay out potential,
uh,
strategies for treatment,
all of that.
And so,
uh,
and that's good enough.
You don't take on any more than that.
So,
okay.
Procrastination and instant rule me.
Nothing seems to motivate me.
What do I do?
Well,
I'm going to give you some practical
advice.
Um,
I would say you need a plan.
Like you need a plan and not just a
plan.
You need a reason to implement the plan.
You need both of those.
So something motivates you.
You already said instant gratification
motivates you.
So you'll do things for instant
gratification.
Now look,
instant gratification is a particular
form of reward.
It's called incentive reward,
and it's mediated by dopaminergic
circuitry.
The same circuitry that mediates reward
as a consequence of using drugs like
cocaine or any of the drugs that people
abuse.
And so there are certain short term
activities that are pleasurable enough.
So they produce,
uh,
an intrinsic,
they intrinsically produce a dopamine
kick.
And a lot of that,
it's instantaneous gratification.
Like,
say eating when you're hungry,
at least a taste and flavor of the food.
Because there's also a satiation element
that comes along with food.
And so there's those,
those pleasures that speak for
themselves when you're looking at the
long run,
things that are rewards that are delayed
don't produce as much of a,
um,
a dopamine kicks.
So they're not as immediately gratifying
and they're not as gripping in the
present.
And the way that you have to overcome
that is to generate a vision of,
it's really,
it's not a,
it's not a plan or a strategy,
it's a philosophical vision that,
that,
that justifies your life in some way
that you deeply believe has to be that.
And it can't be trivial because
otherwise procrastination and instant
gratification are going to rule you.
So we developed this program called the
future authoring program,
and it's part of the self authoring
suite.
And I'll run through it very rapidly
because even if you don't use that
program,
although you could,
because that's what it's designed for
and I think it makes it easier.
It outlines what's necessary in order to
overcome the problem that you're
describing.
So the first question you might ask
yourself is,
well,
what would you need to gain?
And you have to have a real dialogue
with yourself to understand this.
You'll have to take yourself warts and
all your useless,
procrastinating,
instant gratification seeking self.
And you have to sit down and say,
all right,
you know,
you're talking to your inner badly
behaved six year old.
It's like,
okay,
what is it that you would have to have
in order to commit to something in the
long run?
What?
What kind of vision of the future would,
would justify sacrifices for you?
And you might say,
well,
you don't know.
It's like,
okay,
fine.
That's why you have to break it down.
So let me ask you some questions.
So you might think,
well,
here's some things that people need in
their life because your life is not
going to be solid,
grounded,
gratifying,
acceptable,
meaningful,
relevant,
and uh,
devoid of earth,
shaking anxiety without managing some of
these things.
Most people need an intimate
relationship,
a long term intimate relationship
because otherwise they get lonesome and
board and crazy,
crazy in a different way than you get if
you have a longterm relationship.
Worst,
crazy.
Um,
they need friends,
they need family.
So that could be your,
your birth family,
your parents,
your extended family,
your siblings,
but also children.
So you need to,
to know,
well,
where does that fit into your life?
What's your vision for that?
Do you wanna get along with your
parents?
You want to get along with your
siblings?
Do you have a strategy for that?
Do you want to have kids?
At some point?
You want to build yourself a family?
Okay,
you need a job or a career.
Now a career is intrinsically meaningful
and,
and usually very demanding in terms of
commitment and hours,
whereas a job at least can be engaging
in worthwhile.
Um,
it's usually more time limited.
Maybe you have more freedom outside of
it,
but you need a job because you need
something to do and you need some,
some routine and you need some financial
support.
And if you can have a career and that's
what you want,
so much the better.
But at least at least you could have a
trade,
something worthwhile,
not that a trade can't be a career.
And believe me,
I've got nothing against traits.
Um,
you need to take care of yourself
mentally and physically.
Like how do you want to present yourself
in the world?
No,
you want to be healthy mentally and
physically so that you're like a light
among men.
Let's put it that way.
That would be a good goal.
Um,
how are you going to handle the
temptations of drugs and alcohol and
whatever,
procrastination and instant
gratification or tilting you in the
wrong direction.
So those are,
you know,
seven things that you might consider sit
down.
Here's the question.
You're taking care of yourself,
like you or someone you care about.
You can design a future that would be
good for you.
If you were taking care of yourself,
right?
For 20 minutes,
you can have what you want.
It's three years down the road.
You can have whatever you want,
but you have to aim for it and work for
it,
and you have to specify it.
What is it?
What do you want?
What would make your life worthwhile?
What would be good enough?
So that instant gratification would be
an obstacle instead of a means for
proceeding.
Like,
I can give you an example to some
degree.
You know,
when I was kid in my early twenties I
did,
I,
I did quite a bit of drinking and
partying.
I came from a hard drinking background
up in northern Alberta and um,
you know,
I was out three times a week even when I
was in graduate school and I was
beginning to write seriously scientific
papers and also the work that became
maps of meaning and eventually 12 rules
for life.
And it came to the point where I
couldn't do both.
I couldn't go out and be that social and
have that much instinct,
instant gratifying,
fun,
and be in good enough shape so that if I
was editing something complex,
I was making it better instead of worse.
And I was really interested in what I
was doing.
I was learning a lot about the brain.
I was learning a lot about alcohol and
drug abuse.
I was laying out the platform for the
relationship narrative and neuroscience
and it was really engrossing and
engaging,
but it was hard and it was long term.
I mean it was a longterm plan or I had
to make a choice.
It was either continue the fund,
which was fun.
I really enjoyed it or do this thing
that I really believed was more
worthwhile and it was more worthwhile to
do the more worthwhile thing,
which is why I stopped with the,
it's instant gratification,
like a lot of stopping,
and this is true for most people,
especially young men who tend to drink a
fair bit and carouse around a lot.
Most young men stop that sort of thing,
at least to some degree around 25 or 26
and the reason they do that is because
they pick up other responsibilities.
They get a real job that has some future
and they get a relationship that's
permanent.
They have a family and they decide,
well,
that's more important than the
procrastination and the instant
gratification.
Okay,
so make yourself a damn plan.
Make it into a strategy.
You could use the future authoring
program if you like.
I would highly recommend that.
Do it badly.
You might be intimidated by it.
You know?
I don't know how to plan.
It's like,
yeah,
we know you don't know how to plan.
Make a bad plan.
It's better than the one you've got,
so,
so do it badly and then try and modify
it as as needs be and see if that works.
You need a philosophy,
cody.
That's the thing.
You know you're,
you're living in a shallow life and so
short term avoidance,
that's procrastination.
You'll do that because you don't think
it's important enough.
You don't think that the negative
consequences of not doing what you
should do are severe enough.
You're not afraid enough of it.
The other thing you do in the future
authoring program,
by the way,
is right about just exactly what kind of
hell you'd be likely to descend into
three to five years in the future.
If you let your bad habits,
procrastination and instant
gratification,
let's say rule you and take you out of
the game completely because you also
need to be terrified as well as hopeful
about what you might do if you got your
act together.
You need to be terrified about what you,
where you might end up if you kept being
like lazy and useless,
you know,
and shallow and that none of that's
good.
So you need to be deeper and you need to
look deeper.
You need to,
Nisha said he who has a why can bear any
how,
and you need a why and the why is
something like,
well,
imagine you could have the life.
Imagine you could have a life that would
be worth giving up some of the instant
gratification for even in principle,
what would that look like?
So,
all right.
All right.
What do you think the Feminine Hero
Journey is?
Do you believe females have their own
archetypal story to follow?
Well,
yes,
they certainly do.
I think the,
the first of all,
they have the hero story like men do.
But I think,
I think the,
the classic hero story if,
imagine it this way,
the classic hero's story is the
archetypal male story with,
with the feminine lurking in the
background.
Cause like men are adventurous heroes,
all things considered fundamentally.
But they're also very maternal men take
care of children,
families for very long periods of time.
So as far as,
um,
if you think about this from a purely
biological perspective,
human males are very maternal.
So both males and females have an aspect
to them that's archetipal typically
masculine and archetypically feminine.
And I would say in the typical male,
the archetype of the masculine dominates
with the archetypically feminine in the
background.
And then the typical female,
it's the reverse.
And so although there might be some
variation in that,
you know,
you,
you get the relatively rare female who's
more archetypally male in their
orientation to the world and you get the
relatively rare male who is more
archetypally female,
feminine.
So the Dragon,
the conflict with the dragon is the
archetipal male story.
Go Out,
confront the drag and get the gold,
bring it back to the community,
rescue the Virgin,
uh,
enable the community.
Why make yourself wise as a consequence
of the adventure and develop your
character?
That's a great story.
Um,
the archetypal feminine narrative at
least to some degree is beauty and the
beast,
which is to encounter the monstrous
masculine and to tame and civilize it so
that there,
so that a joint relationship can be
established.
That's part and parcel of the
development of longterm intimacy.
And that would be partly for the
purposes of intimacy,
which is particularly important to
people say who are high in agreeableness
and women are higher in agreeableness,
but also as the platform for,
um,
for raising children successfully.
Now you get a male variant of that,
which is one of the male variants of the
same story that,
uh,
Eric Norman in particular talked about.
He was a union commentator.
He wrote a book called origins and
history of consciousness,
which I would highly recommend that's on
my list of recommended readings.
And another one called the great mother,
another brilliant book,
uh,
noise and talked about something called
the crystallization of the anima from
the great mother archetype.
And so you might say that that men
who've been dominated by women,
a young boy who's been dominated by his
mother,
for example,
or a man for,
for who,
who for some reason is dominated and
intimidated by the idea of the rejecting
feminine.
And if you're interested in that idea,
you could watch a documentary called
crump.
You'll see exactly what I mean by
dominated by the archetipal rejecting
feminine.
I'd never seen a better example of it
that then and what's laid out in that
documentary crump to brilliant
documentary.
So the female is a hostile judge and
very critical of men.
The Feminine Speaking Archetipal
[inaudible].
And so the man has to steel himself to
face that rejection,
to develop his character.
Just like a Bill Murray does in
groundhog day.
Exactly the same story.
And then free the individual woman with
whom he has a relationship from the
archetipal judgemental feminine.
So that's like the male version of
beauty and the beast.
And so then,
and the female version,
obviously the hero archetype is the fact
that women do have heroic role to play
in the world as well because they
confront the unknown just like men do
and Garner,
um,
wisdom,
knowledge,
riches as a consequence.
But the way I look at it is that,
well,
for females,
the feminine archetype is at the
forefront and the masculine at the
background and,
and it's reversed for men.
So that's,
that's how it looks to me.
So you caught some twitter flack for
your comment on Brett Kavanaugh care to
address your comment and the blowback?
Well,
I addressed the comment because I wrote
a blog post and so that was probably the
right way,
not only to address it,
but that would have been the right way
to handle it to begin with.
So I'll,
I'll,
I'll address it.
Sure.
I'll address it and all address the blow
back as well.
Look.
Okay.
Just because you have an idea doesn't
mean that it's the only idea and just
because you have an idea doesn't mean
it's right.
And so like it's weird for me in some
sense to engage in public discourse,
especially politically because you see,
I'd been in,
I'd been a researcher for a very long
period of time and so most of the people
that I've talked to about serious ideas,
most of them,
many of them have been researchers,
graduate students for example.
And when you're talking about a problem,
whatever it might be,
if your research oriented,
what you do is kind of what you do if
you're a therapist.
The way I laid out advice for a young
therapist earlier,
it's like,
okay,
well what does everybody think the
problem is?
And so you,
you assume that you don't know.
It's like,
okay,
well we have big discussion about what
everybody thinks the problem is.
Well,
what do you think the real problem is?
Like what's the real problem with the
cavenaugh situation?
Well one might be,
well cavenaugh was accused of sexual
impropriety when he was a high school
student and because of that,
he's not his suitability for the Supreme
Court is in question.
Maybe that's the problem.
Yeah,
maybe.
And maybe that's not the problem.
Who the hell knows what the problem is?
So here's a bunch of possibilities.
Um,
we haven't had a reasonable discussion
about what constitutes an acceptable,
a statute of limitations with regards to
accusations of misbehavior between
individuals.
It's like,
well,
can you accuse someone reasonably five
years later,
10 years later,
15 years later,
40 later.
Like is there a limit?
Do you,
is there a more,
do you have a moral obligation if you're
going to accuse someone or even seek
justice to do that within a reasonable
period of time?
Who knows?
We don't.
So that's a problem.
Um,
what exactly are the rules that govern
the conduct of men and women when
they're young,
when they're drinking?
Are we going to have that conversation?
No,
we're not going to have that
conversation either because no one wants
to think that through and they
especially don't want to think it
through.
With regards to the complicating
additional feature of alcohol thing
about alcohol is the reason that people
drink is so that they can act stupidly
and have fun.
Now the problem with acting stupidly and
having fun when you're sober is that it
makes you anxious and so you don't do
it.
But Al calls,
especially for people for whom alcohol
is a good drug,
ramps up the excitement of impulsivity
and quells the anxiety.
And so people always drink,
often drink because they want to go out
and be stupid and have fun.
And look,
I understand that there's something to
be said for stupid fun,
but it's,
but one of the things that also needs to
be said about it is it's bloody well
dangerous and so we don't want to have
that conversation.
We don't have that conversation on
campuses.
We talk about the rape crisis.
Nobody talks about the alcohol,
sexual assault crisis.
If men and women didn't drink together,
there'd be virtually no sexual assault.
And in fact,
if people didn't drink at all,
there'd be almost no violent crime
because alcohol contributes to violent
crime in a manner that you can hardly
imagine.
But 50% of people who are murdered are
drunk.
And about 50% of the people who do the
murdering or drunk.
And that's probably an underestimate
because the stats aren't kept that well.
And it also depends.
It depends on how you define drunk.
So that could also be a problem.
Um,
well the liberals left types,
let's call them the left leaning.
Progressive types,
don't want a conservative on the Supreme
Court of the left leaning types aren't
happy that trump won the election.
Um,
the conservatives want to rush our
candidate onto the supreme court come
hell or high water because of the
November election.
Um,
then there's another problem.
Well,
is this about cavenaugh at all?
Or is this about roe and weighed in
about abortion?
Well,
who knows,
right?
It's about all those things.
So it's an unbelievably complicated,
godawful situation.
And so Eric Weinstein and Bret Weinstein
were tweeting about this and it was late
at night.
And Eric said,
as far as I can tell,
either way,
this is not going to end well.
And I thought,
oh.
And he said,
is there an alternative?
Is there a way out of that?
And I thought,
oh,
that's an interesting question.
What might be a way out of that?
And I thought,
well,
Calvin was in a rough position because
he can't withdraw obviously and perhaps
shouldn't,
um,
without his reputation being shattered.
And if he doesn't get nominated,
same thing is life is basically over.
So,
but on the other hand,
he's tangled up in a scandal that's
sufficient merck and mud so that it
isn't self evident that he can serve as
a supreme court justice without having
every single one of his decisions,
especially in contentious cases,
produce a tremendous amount of social
upheaval over the next two or three
decades.
And it isn't obvious that that's a great
move forward.
No,
it might be fine.
I mean,
there's been
controversy around other Supreme Court
justice nominations and that seems to
have basically sorted itself out.
And I already said,
just because you're thinking something
through doesn't mean you're right.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a simulation.
So I thought,
well if I was in cabinet has position
and I felt that my candidacy had been
compromised,
perhaps through no fault of my own,
I have not saying anything about his
innocence or guilt,
but that my candidacy had been
compromised by this interminable and
ugly scandal.
And that meant that my tenure on the
Supreme Court might be marked by
culturally divisive controversy in the
long run.
Maybe it would be better for me to be
nominated to say,
look,
it's too murky,
it's too muddy and I don't think the
country is best served by my accepting
the nomination.
Then the conservatives can nominate
another candidate,
get their personal on the supreme court.
So there's no necessary lost there.
And perhaps we could move forward with a
minimum relative minimum of
divisiveness.
No,
look in my blog I laid out all the
reasons why that isn't a good idea.
Like here maybe if you just give me five
seconds,
I can read some of them.
Cause I tried to make a steel man case
for why my idea wasn't a good one.
My idea about him withdrawing.
So just give me one second and I'll read
all the potential objections just so
that you know that I've thought them
through.
Um,
okay.
So perhaps the Democrat opposition would
mount a similar campaign against my
punitive successor.
Well,
that's certainly possible.
I said,
well,
that would provide virtually
unassailable evidence for the purely
manipulative and political motivation of
the accusers,
forcing them to duplicate their strategy
as second time.
That would help reveal the machinations
for what they were in a manner that
would be virtually in dot.
Undeniable.
Perhaps time is of the essence and
there'd be no way to place another
candidate of conservative leaning on the
bench before the November elections as
they say.
However,
act in haste,
repent in leisure.
Okay.
And then other,
other,
um,
arguments against my position.
Here they are.
Oh yes.
If cavenaugh withdrew after being,
here's what might happen,
it would be read as an admission of
guilt on his part.
It would embolden those who would use
reputation destruction as a political
maneuver.
It would weaken the generally and
vitally important idea of the
presumption of innocence.
It would indicate weakness on the part
of the Republicans at a key moment prior
to the November elections.
It would mean that an innocent man has
been successfully pilloried by a mob.
It would validate the use of allegations
of past behavior well past any
reasonable expiry date as a weapon.
It would destroy the Republican
opportunity to choose a supreme court
justice hand,
the Democrats and unearned victory
embitter bitter,
a large percentage of the conservative
base who would regard the withdrawal as
a betrayal and last and perhaps least
violate my own personal adage for what
that's worth of.
Don't apologize if you haven't done
anything wrong.
Okay,
so I understand the weaknesses of that
position.
Um,
I was putting it forward as a potential
third alternative.
Now look,
it's perfectly reasonable to put things
to out,
to put things forward as alternatives.
That's thinking.
Now having said that,
I made some mistakes.
Okay.
So the first mistake was
don't tweet complicated ideas in 140
characters about contentious issues in
the midst of a controversy at two in the
morning.
Right?
Bad idea.
And so one of the consequences of this
for me is that I've withdrawn quite a
lot over the last three weeks from
twitter.
It's twitter,
it's a very dangerous platform.
And so I'm taking a break from it while
I'm reevaluating its utility.
And so I,
I,
cause I talked to my son about this
before and other members of my family
and we had agreed that I wasn't going to
post anything on twitter that should be
made into a blog.
But the problem with twitter is that it,
or the problem with me,
who knows where the problem is,
is that twitter invites and facilitates
impulsive responding.
And so I'm not convinced that it's
necessarily a good platform for me.
I have all the places that I tend to get
into trouble.
Twitter is sort of at the top of the
list now.
I laid out in my blog why I still use
it.
I feel some moral obligation to the
almost a million people who follow me on
twitter for example.
And there's an addictive quality to it
too.
You know,
I'm following a lot of these people in
the intellectual dark web and seeing
what they're up to and trying to keep an
eye on the cultural climate,
let's say.
And it's not easy to figure out for me
as it sure is the case for all of you,
exactly how much you should be exposed
to such things and how much you should
protect yourself.
I mean,
a case could certainly be made that I
should stay the hell off twitter and do
nothing but write for the next year
cause it's not like I have any shortage
of things to write about.
So I'm trying to sort that out.
So,
um,
that's my explanation.
And um,
and it could easily be that,
as I said,
it could easily be that the idea that I
put forward wasn't the best idea.
You know,
who knows what the best ideas.
Maybe the best idea was for cavenaugh to
do exactly what he did,
who knows.
So,
and more,
you know,
good luck to him and to the Supreme
Court.
I hope it all stabilizes.
That would be lovely.
And it has happened before.
And so maybe it will again.
So,
all right,
I took the understand myself test and
have a question.
Okay.
So the understand myself
tests@understandmyself.com for all of
the,
those of you who don't know is a
personality test.
It's based on the big five extroversion,
neuroticism,
agreeableness,
conscientiousness,
openness.
It breaks each of them down into two
fundamental aspects that have been
empirically validated.
And so you can take that test.
I put a code in the description of this
video.
Uh,
I think the code is October.
You can use that code for self authoring
and for understand myself.
And there's a 20% discount for that.
So if you want to do that only takes
about 15 minutes to do the understand
myself tasked,
by the way,
the self authoring program,
that requires more effort and you have
to do that over a number of days.
But you can do it badly,
as I said,
and you need a plan man.
You need to know where you are.
That's the autobiographical part.
And you need a plan for the future.
So it's worth it.
Even though it's hard,
it,
it's not as hard as stumbling through
your life blindly.
Okay,
I took the understand myself test and
have a question.
Should I take the results as is and live
trying to cope with them or can I try to
change them to some degree?
All right,
so the first thing is I would say,
well,
take the results as they are to some
degree.
Now it depends.
Look,
you gotta be careful because if you take
a personality test like this and you're
depressed,
so you know the future looks really
bleak to you,
the president looks bleak.
When you look into the past,
almost everything looks negative.
You know,
you're not taking any pleasure in
things.
You feel bad.
Perhaps even worse in the morning,
you,
you're,
you can't see any light in your life.
You're very self critical.
Perhaps you're depressed.
Then if you're depressed,
your personality scores are going to
look,
um,
they're going to be skewed as a
consequence of that.
And so they might be more negative
because of the mindset that you have
when you take the test then they truly
are.
So I'm assuming with this answer that
you're not depressed.
So,
um,
should I take the results as he is in
live trying to cope with them?
Well,
one thing is you should at least give
yourself some credit.
It's like you're a particular way.
So let's say you're low in openness.
Just for the sake of argument.
Let's say you're low in openness and
moderately high in conscientiousness.
You're a more conservative person.
You're probably going to be happier if
you take a more conservative path in
life,
you're going,
you're not,
if you're low in openness,
you not that creative,
you're not going to be interested in
aesthetics.
You're not going to be interested even
in ideas to that greater degree.
It's not your area of fascination.
You're more practical and concrete and
perhaps and also less flighty and less
prone to,
to create of error.
There's advantages to,
you know,
because most creative people,
um,
our fonts of ideas that will work and
that will occupy a tremendous amount of
counter productive time in their
implementation.
That's the downside to creativity,
false positives.
Um,
if you're disagreeable,
well then you're going to try to work
somewhere where competent
competitiveness is useful.
If you're high in neuroticism,
then you're probably going to have to
find a job where the stress levels
aren't too high.
If you're introverted,
you want to find a place where you could
work and spend a fair bit of time by
yourself.
You know you want to match your
environment to your personality.
That's adaptation to some degree.
Now,
if you're really high in neuroticism for
example,
and you're too anxious and then there
are things that you can do about that,
you know that that's something you might
want to.
If it's really out of hand,
say if you're 98th percentile or above,
something like that,
and it's also making you suffer because
you're too anxious and too risk averse
and to volatile.
You might want to consider something
like counseling to see if you can get
your anxiety levels down or to learn to
meditate or to learn to control your
breathing or or,
or,
or to talk to someone to see if there's
some physiological reason for that.
Now you can change,
but like if you're introverted and you
can develop social skills,
but you kind of have to do them one at a
time,
you know,
because it's not something that comes
naturally to you and it might not be
something that you developed as a child.
You have to consciously plan a social
strategy.
So you might say,
well,
I'm introverted.
I should go out with someone for lunch
once a week.
I should see friends twice a week,
right?
You should.
You need to make a plan for social
interactions.
And if you're extroverted and you can't
stand being alone,
well then you might practice being alone
a little bit so that you can learn how
to spend some quality time on yourself
and not be so dependent on the company
of others.
If you're an agreeable person,
too agreeable,
then you'll need to figure out what it
is that you want,
what you're resentful about and what you
need to negotiate about on your own
behalf.
And if you're really disagreeable,
then you might want to think hard about
consciously deciding that once a week or
so you're going to try to do something
for someone else.
And there's a research literature on
that actually a,
it indicates quite clearly that if you
consciously plan to do something
altruistic on a regular basis,
it does seem to improve overall
wellbeing.
And I think that's particularly
important for disagreeable people
because they don't do that naturally.
It doesn't come to them naturally.
So I think that you,
the,
the general advice is find an
environment where your temperament works
and then the more specific advices.
While having said that,
it doesn't hurt to expand your
temperament.
If you're introverted,
you should be able to do extroverted
people do.
And if you're extroverted,
you should be able to spend time alone.
You should develop those as skills.
If you're an agreeable person,
you should learn how to negotiate for
yourself in a tough minded manner.
And if you're disagreeable,
you should learn to take other people
into consideration more if you're
unconscientious wouldn't hurt.
To have a schedule,
like a Google calendar and to start
working on that because la low
conscientiousness is going to interfere
with your longterm success.
And if you're hyper conscientious,
well,
you might need to learn to relax a
little bit and to make that a priority.
So when,
if you're high in openness,
well,
I don't have a quick answer for what you
do if you're high in openness.
Oh,
I do.
I guess I do to some degree,
try to focus on one thing to some degree
on one thing and get good at that.
Because when you're open,
you're flying out all over the place
latterly and you can easily become a
dilettante's.
So one of the things you have to do if
you're high in openness is develop true
expertise in at least one place.
You can even pick it somewhat arbitrary
given that you're interested in
everything.
Commit to something.
If you're low in openness and the little
closed off compared to what you should
be,
a little narrow minded,
let's say,
and conventional.
Um,
maybe you should read a book a week.
Join a book club.
That's a good thing to do.
Um,
okay,
that's a,
that's a good start.
Join a book club.
Um,
and,
and open yourself up a little bit.
Go see a movie now and then as well.
That would also be helpful,
you know?
And,
and that will widen you out a bit.
And that's important.
You know,
what's important for your career and all
that sort of thing.
You want to,
you know,
your temperament to puts you in a
certain place in the distribution and it
isn't so much that you want to move the
place is that you want to move the
variability so that you can be what you
need to be when the situation demands
it.
And that doesn't mean to blow in the
wind.
It means to be adaptable instead of
constrained tightly by your biological
predisposition.
And you can learn that it's painstaking.
It,
it requires a lot of effort,
but you can learn it.
So
my daughter's school is now teaching
gender as a social construct for sexes.
Avoids naming boys and girls.
What did we do?
Leaving is not an option.
Well,
I guess the first question is,
I'm,
I'll,
I'll just take you at your word.
That leaving is not an option.
It certainly might not be an option.
Um,
I would say
your best bet,
and this is a casual piece of advice
because I don't know your particular
situation,
is to find out how many parents there
are around who are also not happy about
this.
And then start to strategize.
I mean,
look,
to some degree what people define as
gender is a social construct.
So let's look at it this way.
So there are things that make men,
men and that make women,
women that are universal across
cultures.
So let's say,
except for tiny variations,
um,
external genitalia.
So,
but then there are things that do vary
across culture with regards to whether
they're regarded as masculine or
feminine,
male or female.
And those are more learned.
So let's say that external genitalia is
not a social construct.
It's not learned.
If we can't agree on that,
then we're not going to be able to have
a discussion at all.
So,
but there are some things about male
behavior and some things about female
behavior that are culture specific and
learned.
And so to that degree,
gender is a social construct.
So,
so you know,
you have to give the devil his due,
but
the problem isn't teaching that gender
is a social construct.
That problem is teaching the gender is
only a social construct and that's just
wrong.
It's absolutely wrong.
As soon as someone's doing that,
then you know that you're dealing with
an idiot log.
And the research evidence on that,
for example,
is crystal clear.
Apart from the fact that there are
morphological differences between men
and women,
which are quite obvious.
Um,
you can name a variety of the men have
wider jaws,
they have larger teeth,
they can bite harder,
they have thicker skulls.
As women certainly can attest to from a
psychological perspective,
they are more powerful in the upper
body.
They can punch a lot harder there.
They can throw more naturally.
Um,
they're,
uh,
they,
they tend to weigh more,
they tend to be taller.
That's sexual dimorphism.
Human beings are relatively sexually
dimorphic as far as primates.
And other mammals go.
Um,
they,
there's difference in,
in obviously a waist to hip ratio,
um,
women's elbows or a different angle.
They have finer bones.
Women have a subcutaneous layer of body
fat that men don't have.
Um,
women are a little bit more pain
resistant,
um,
made more pain tolerant.
They're also,
uh,
they also have very high levels of
stamina.
Um,
women tend to be,
have a little edge in verbal ability.
Men tend to have a little edge in
spatial ability.
Um,
and then there are,
apart from the straight physiological
differences,
there are psychological differences and
there's a variety of them.
Um,
women are more enthusiastic,
men are more assertive.
That's extroversion.
Women are higher in withdrawal and in
volatility.
That's on the neuroticism front.
Women are more agreeable and more
polite.
That's on the agreeableness front.
Men are more industrious,
slightly and women are more orderly.
That's on the conscientious front.
And women are higher in openness proper
and men are higher in interest in ideas.
And that's on the openness front.
And those differences aren't huge.
There's more overlap between the
genders,
the sexist than there are.
And there is lack of overlap,
but the differences magnify at the
extremes and they also um,
maximize in societies that are
egalitarian.
And then the biggest difference between
men and women that we know of
psychologically is that men are more
prone to be interested in things and
women are more prone to be interested in
people.
And that's actually quite a large
difference by psychological standards
and there isn't any evidence that that
is socially constructed.
The counter evidence is that as you make
society's more egalitarian,
those differences actually get bigger
rather than smaller.
And even the London Times three weeks
ago wrote an editorial describing and
not yet another study that demonstrated
that.
So that's like six and they're huge,
huge scale studies pointing out that
this,
the fact that the differences between
men and women get bigger in more
egalitarian societies is now one of the
most well established findings in all of
the social sciences.
Thus demonstrating,
for example,
that poor James Damore was correct
despite the fact that Google fired him
for being accurate in his analysis of
the scientific literature.
Okay.
So you've got the facts on your side.
Problem is is you don't know what to do.
Well there's only one of you that's not
a good number.
If you're going to mount a campaign,
you annoyed about this.
Well write down exactly what you're
annoyed about.
What bothers you about this?
Okay,
what would you like to have happen?
Because you need to know what the
problem is and you need to know what
this solution is.
Then you have to start thinking about
strategy and one strategy is you need
some allies.
You need some people on your side.
Now if this is bothering you,
the probability that it's bothering most
people is very high because it's very
rare,
especially with something like this.
I mean I would say,
and I think the data's support this is
that the overwhelming majority of people
do not believe that gender is a social
construct construct.
That there are four sexes and that
avoiding naming boys and girls is a good
idea.
So you've got,
unless you're in a very progressive
place,
in which case that's it's own problem,
he got to find some people who would be
willing to go to bat with you.
And then you have to find it's a
political struggle.
It's a bit of a war.
It's like,
okay,
who's pushing this?
Who's the ring leaders for this?
You know,
it's,
it's certainly possible that most of the
teachers don't want to do this either.
But they're afraid to say anything.
So I would say there's probably a two
year campaign and you have to decide if
this is something that you want to put
your time and effort into.
And if you do,
you have to conduct it like a,
like a war,
you know,
without the violence obviously.
But it,
but that's the right metaphor.
It's like what's the set of problems?
Who's causing them?
What do you want to have happen as a
concept,
as an alternative?
How are you going to tackle this?
You're going to talk to your,
to your local public authorities,
school authorities.
You're going to talk to the local
politicians in to talk to the principal.
Are you going to face down the teachers?
Are you going to do that with more than
one of you?
Are you going to have your arguments in
order,
you know,
art.
And then on a more personal front,
what are you going to do with your
daughter?
How are you going to educate her?
Let's say you decide not to take this
on,
on the political or public front,
then you have to have a conversation
with her and find out what she thinks,
you know,
because she'll be doubtful and dubious
about all of this.
So a lot of that should be asking her
questions,
you know,
so yeah,
that's the best I can do with that.
Would you consider adding a list of
recommended movies to your website?
Yes,
I've thought about that.
Also a recommended list of books for,
for young people.
Um,
it's on the hypothetical list of things
to do.
Um,
but I haven't done it yet.
So,
and it,
I don't think that it's likely to make
it up the priority list for awhile
because I'm pretty booked out for the
next,
who knows how long a while.
Um,
cannot understand myself or other big
five test be taken after some time.
Eg,
one to two years and be fairly accurate.
I asked because I believe I have
changed.
Well,
you might've changed.
I mean,
look,
first of all,
people do change as they mature.
Personality is relatively stable across
time,
but relatively stable doesn't mean
completely stable.
It means that,
you know,
if you were extremely extroverted,
the probability that in five years
you're going to be extremely introverted
is very low.
But if you were extremely extroverted,
it's conceivable that you know,
in one or two years you'll be a
moderately extroverted,
you can move.
And some of that's,
some of that's situational.
Um,
some of it's learning,
some of it's maturation.
So one of the most reliable findings in
the personality literature is that as
people get older,
they get more conscientious,
more agreeable,
and more emotionally stable,
less neurotic.
And that those three traits clump to
make a super trade called,
we called it stability.
So people get more stable as they get
older,
you know,
and I've seen people learn to be more
conscientious,
that's for sure that happens.
That happens.
I think whenever you take people who
are,
who are young and sort of flighty and
put them through a rigorous
apprenticeship program,
you know,
where they disciplined themselves.
And I've seen people become certainly
become less lower in neuroticism and
less agreeable for that matter.
So,
so yes,
you can take them.
Sure.
Take it again two years later and,
and,
and see,
you know,
the other thing you can do if you're
really curious about your personality is
have some other people take the
personality test about you.
Cause you know some things about your
personality and they're accurate to some
degree.
Self report has some degree of accuracy,
but then you can get information from
other people as well.
And so that's another way of
determining,
um,
you know,
if a helping of helping get an accurate
picture of who you are.
So,
um,
you can change drum,
the more dramatic the change,
the more effort is required.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
So,
um,
we know,
for example,
that you can change Iq with shift in
socioeconomic status.
So imagine that you have identical twins
separated at birth and you know,
you put one twin into a relatively well
off family and one twin into a
relatively poor family.
And let's assume that being rich has
some advantages with regards to
intellectual development.
You need a three standard,
if I remember correctly,
you need a three standard deviation
might be four,
but you need a three or four standard
deviation move upward in socioeconomic
status to produce a one standard
deviation increase in Iq.
So you have to move from something like
the fifth percentile.
I might have the stats a bit wrong
because I'm trying to do this on the
fly.
You have to move from the bottom fifth
percentile to the top fifth percentile
in wealth to move from average
intelligence to 85th percentile in
intelligence.
So you can change as a consequence of
the situation,
but the bigger the change,
the more costly and that could be costly
in terms of resources or effort.
So
when you like doing a podcast with Elon
Musk,
let's start an initiative for this.
Yes,
I would like to do a podcast with Elon
Musk.
I know people who know him,
uh,
but we've never met.
Um,
yes,
I'm sure that would be ridiculously fun.
So if you want to start an initiative
for that,
you go right ahead.
And who knows,
maybe it'll bear fruit.
Um,
I am going to be concentrating more on
my podcast in a few months.
I'm contracting with a professional
company to develop it so that it,
well for a variety of reasons so that it
moves higher up on the priority list.
So I have a better studio.
Um,
so that I have some staff to help me,
uh,
schedule interviews.
There's lots of people I want to talk to
authors and scientists and politicians
and,
and so I'm quite excited about that.
So,
so,
and I would love to talk to Elon Musk's,
um,
I'm sure that would be ridiculously fun.
I would,
I would love to find out.
I'd like to ask him about his thought
process.
And also I'm really curious about how in
the world he manages to do multiple
impossible things because doing one
impossible thing is impossible,
but doing like five impossible things is
the product of five impossibilities.
And that just seems like hyper
impossible.
But he's managed it,
you know,
I mean,
think about it.
Think about what he did.
He built an electric car,
which is like hard,
and then he built a rocket and then he
blasted the car into space on his rocket
like that.
That's not,
that's not real.
That doesn't happen.
But it did happen and he did it.
And so I would really,
I would love to talk to him.
I think that would be extremely,
extremely interesting.
How do you fight a monster without
becoming one yourself?
You don't.
You become a monster by fighting with a
monster,
but it's actually a good thing to become
a monster.
You see the differences,
and really this is the answer to your
question.
You could stay naive and that's not good
because you're vulnerable and you're not
useful if you're naive.
So that's a bad situation.
So let's say,
well instead of being naive,
you decide you're going to go confront
the monster.
Okay,
well the problem with that is that you
become the monster.
All right,
so how do you deal with that?
And the answer is to do it voluntarily
to do it voluntarily.
Because if you develop your
monstrousness voluntarily,
then perhaps you can bring it under
civilized control,
right?
You can integrate those,
the,
those,
that capacity for May hem and
destruction that you develop within
yourself.
You can integrate that within a
comprehensive and properly directed
practical philosophy.
And so that means that you're
disciplined,
you know,
like a warrior isn't a monster,
so you have to,
you have to align,
you have to discipline your monstrosity,
and you do that by developing it
voluntarily.
Look,
you see this sort of thing happening all
the time in classic hero stories.
Like if you look at the story of the
Hobbit,
for example,
like,
um,
Bilbo,
I think Bilbo is the harbor,
right?
Photos.
The next one.
Let me just look that up.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's Bilbo good.
That's what I thought.
Now Bill Bolt,
when he starts,
when this Harvard starts the book,
Bilbo lives in this little protected
area.
So it's like,
it's like the castle that the Buddha
grows up in.
All the bad things are outside of it.
And the reason for that actually is
because of the kingdom is guarded by
these descendants of great kings.
The striders who the hobbits have some
contempt for cause they kind of look
like tramps.
Aragorn is one of them.
So the descendants of great kings patrol
the borders and keep the naive and habit
and some of the shyer safe.
And there are naive and they go about
their day to day work and nothing really
threatened them.
And there's no monsters around.
And because they don't have any real
challenges and because they're peaceful
in their wealth and security,
they think they're good,
but they're,
they're just naive and undisciplined and
relatively weak.
And so they're not prepared for
anything.
When all hell breaks loose.
They're,
they're,
they're like,
they're like bait.
They're like prey,
you know.
So,
and of course the wizard,
um,
Gandalf knows this now despite the fact
that the sugar folk are rather small and
a bit comical and tremendously naive.
They do have a latent ability for
courage and,
and,
and forthrightness and Gandalf can
really see this in the one hobbit,
Bilbo.
And so he tells Bilbo that darkness is
brewing on the outs and the,
in the outlands outside of protected
territory.
Absolutely classic mythological
representation.
It's the same in the lion king where,
um,
Mustafa tells Simba that his kingdom is
everything that the light falls on and
that he's not to journey outside of that
domain.
Right?
That's how the elephant graveyard in
death and all of that,
that's outside of the Shyer,
let's say it's outside of Paradise.
It's outside of the walled city.
It's outside of your domain of
knowledge.
Well,
that's where,
that's where malevolence and chaos,
bruce.
Now you see that again in,
in the lion king because that's where
scar and the hyenas go off to to
conspire and turn into what are
essentially Jack booted Nazis before
they take over the,
the pride land.
Same idea.
Okay,
well,
so what happens to bill bolt when he
goes off to confront the dragon?
He has to become a thief,
right?
Which is very picky.
It's very,
it's very strange ethically because
while bill bill wasn't a thief and you
think,
well,
it's better to be,
to not be a thief than to be a thief.
And the answer to that,
it's very hard answer,
very complicated answer.
And it's not one to be dealt with
lightly.
It's not,
it's not good to be moral if the reason
that your moral is because you cannot be
otherwise.
So that's the naivety issue,
right?
So naive,
it is not morality.
And if you're terrified to be a thief
and you have no skill at it and you're
not a thief,
that doesn't mean you're good.
Now,
if you could be the best thief in the
world,
man,
you were one sneaky character and,
and,
and fast on your feet and a real
strategic thinker and capable of
breaking rules when necessary,
and scaling walls and climbing houses
and infiltrating parties and plotting
for the long run,
and then you decided not to do it,
well then,
then that's a whole different story.
Then you're a moral animal,
right?
So you need that capacity for
criminality.
You need the capacity for criminality,
you need the capacity of evil,
and you need to have mastered that.
And that's what makes you good.
And so while that's what happens in the
harbor is that Bilbo has to develop his
dark side,
his shadow,
and he does that,
you know?
And,
and,
well,
he's a thief and a variety of ways.
He ends up stealing the ring,
which is really interesting.
And of course that that bleeds into the
Lord of the rings.
So,
and,
but the,
you know,
the look,
he doesn't get away Scot free
from developing his dark side.
Like he's touched by evil from then on
and he's got the ring problem and that's
a big one,
that thing that might possess him
because he's got too close to it.
It's like Harry Potter partner in his
scar and the fact that he has a bit of
voldemort hit them.
It's exactly the same idea or the
strange affinity that the joker insists
upon in joker and Batman.
MMM MMM.
When,
when bill bill comes back to the Shire,
like he's never one of the hobbits
again.
He's always an outsider.
He's got a glimmer of magic and danger
about them and that makes people respect
him.
But they also,
they also think that he's unconventional
in an unacceptable way and you know,
kind of make a wide berth around him
because now he's contaminated with,
with evil and the unknown.
Even though that makes them a much
better character,
all things considered and a real fighter
in the battle between good and evil,
and the person who's gone out and
confronted the dragon and got the
treasure,
all of that.
So well,
the pathway to,
from naivety to the full development of
character is associated with the
development in the union sense of the
shadow.
And that's that capacity for mayhem and
malevolence that needs to be brought
under control.
So yes,
it's,
it's complicated.
Um,
and,
and that doesn't mean that you're
justified in going out and breaking
rules because you think that you're
building your character.
You know,
it's not that simple.
If you look out,
um,
if you look at stories like Harry
Potter,
you know,
all of Harry's crew breaks rules,
but they only break a rule when not
breaking.
It would break a higher order rule.
And that's still morally ambivalent,
right?
Because the best pathway forward is to
violate no conventions,
to do the right thing and violate new
conventions.
No,
no conventions.
But now and then you're in a terrible
situation where you can,
you can do a small bad thing or a large
bad thing or you can allow a large,
bad thing to happen by,
by,
by not,
by failing to break a rule that often
happens in Harry Potter.
So then you're in trouble.
And part of being wise and oriented
towards the good is to know when
breaking a rule is the right thing to
do,
even though you shouldn't break rules.
So
yeah,
Canada has legalized marijuana.
What are your thoughts?
It's about time.
That's my thoughts.
I think that once a certain number of
people break a law,
then it's not reasonable to have the
law.
That's part of it.
Um,
it isn't obvious to me that
it was irrational in some sense to have
for marijuana to be illegal,
especially given that alcohol is legal
because all calls way more dangerous
than marijuana.
I'm more or less libertarian on this
front.
It's like
smoke your damn part and try not to act
like too much of a moron when you're
stoned.
That's what it looks like to me.
So,
and,
and I kind of feel that way across the
spectrum of consciousness altering
substances.
It's like,
ew,
ew.
I think that the danger of restricting
people's freedoms unnecessarily is more
dangerous than the danger of not
restricting them.
And so you're entitled to go to hell in
a handbasket in your own manner.
Um,
and hopefully,
but I do think that if you're going to
engage or indulge in your favorite drug
of abuse,
that you should be as little amount of
annoying to everyone around you as you
possibly can be.
Then I would also say with regards to
drug trade in general,
is that here's a bunch of consequences
of the war on drugs.
A lot of the unexpected,
first of all,
terrible incarceration rates,
especially in the United States,
that's not so good.
Second is the dumping of hundreds of
millions or billions of dollars into the
hands of like serious criminals and the
destabilization of much of Central
America as a consequence,
tremendous violence as a consequence.
And then the enriching of people who are
these are seriously committed,
dangerous criminals.
And to give them that much power is a
bad idea.
So maybe the government has to tax and
regulate like it does with cigarettes
and it does with alcohol and to some
degree it does with gambling.
Um,
then the next issue is,
uh,
one of the consequences now of
the,
the
classification of certain drugs as
illegal is that the chemists are faster
than the legislators.
And so what they do is they keep making
variants of addictive drugs.
And now instead of a dozen drugs of
abuse,
which is what we had say 20 years ago,
we have like 300,
and some of them are way more addictive
than the original drugs.
And so it isn't,
it doesn't look like good policy to me.
And I know that places like Portugal,
for example,
have decriminalized every drug of abuse
and it doesn't look like it's been a
catastrophe.
So,
well,
we'll see.
Right?
We legalized marijuana yesterday.
There's no,
the streets aren't full of stone people
bumping into walls.
Nothing's changed.
I hope it works.
I hope that the government regulates it
properly,
that they derive tax revenue from it and
that um,
people use pot a little and that people
use alcohol a little less.
That would be good because alcohol is a
very dangerous drug.
So,
okay.
So I'm going to go for eight more
minutes.
I have to stop comparatively early today
because I have to pack and then I have
to go to Dublin.
And so just to warn you all.
So
do you have any advice on how to vet a
potential marriage partner during the
dating relationship phase?
God,
that's a hard question.
Okay.
So while I can tell you what I've
observed as a consequence of watching,
you know,
all the married people successful and
unsuccessful,
who I know,
but also watching all my clients and
giving this a fair bit of thought.
Um,
here,
here's some of what's necessary for a
successful marriage.
You have to trust the person.
That doesn't mean they can't make
mistakes because you're going to make
mistakes and so are they.
But fundamentally you have to trust
them.
And what that means is that you have to
trust that if things go wrong,
if they make a mistake,
they'll do what was necessary in
conjunction with you to set it right.
You have to be able to negotiate with
the person.
And those two things are tied very,
very close together.
So if you,
you guys have to be able to have a
conversation about what it is that you
want to do,
come to a conclusion,
moderate your differences,
move forward and have that work.
You have to be able to fight and make up
both of those.
If you can't fight with your potential
marriage partner,
then you're not communicating because
there's just no bloody way that you're
going to get along.
There's no way you're gonna agree on
everything.
That's just not going to happen.
So you have to be honest with one
another enough to have some conflict.
But then you have to be able to make up.
That's a huge deal,
man,
because well,
then you get to have conflict and solve
problems and make up.
So trust negotiation,
uh,
conflict resolution.
The next thing I would say is it's kind
of Nice if you're attracted to each
other.
You know,
if there's a strong sexual attraction
there,
it isn't obvious to me that that's
something that can be conjured up if it
doesn't exist.
I haven't seen that happened
successfully.
It's,
that seems to depend on factors that
aren't really under voluntary control.
You know,
I mean obviously people can modify
themselves to some degree to be more or
less attractive,
staying in physical shape and,
and,
and that sort of thing.
Dressing nicely and,
and,
and having a certain amount of sex
appeal and charisma and provocativeness
that's all there.
But that's,
that's all well and good and it's
important.
But I do believe that that spark that's
outside of voluntary control is a
necessary precondition for a long
lasting relationship.
I do believe though that if it's there,
you still have to work very hard to
maintain it as hard in your marriage as
you would when you're dating and you
need to know that.
Um,
then it's also helpful if you actually
like the person,
you know,
if they're your friend that you actually
liked to go do things with them.
Sort of independent of the romantic
element,
you know,
if there,
you don't need to want to do everything
together,
but you should have some things that you
like to do in common.
So some similarity in personality is
useful.
The personality scale is useful for
that.
Like look here,
here it's really hard for an extreme
extrovert and an extreme introvert to
live together because the extreme
extrovert wants to meet with people all
the time and the extreme introvert is
immediately exhausted by that and it's,
neither of those things are precisely
under voluntary control.
Um,
it's really hard for someone super
agreeable and super disagreeable to get
along together because the agreeable
person isn't going to be able to stand
up very well to the disagreeable person
and the disagreeable person is going to
think that the agreeable person is a
pushover.
That's rough.
I,
it's very hard for someone high in
openness and someone very low and
openness to be together because they
open person is like fascinated by ideas
and really interested in this theoretics
and art and philosophy and poetry and
all of that.
And the person who's low in openness,
it's like they're colorblind to that.
It's not in their realm of involuntary
interest.
Conscientiousness,
the same thing.
If if you,
if you're a very conscientious person,
very diligent nose to the grindstone,
um,
industrious and orderly and your partner
can while away at the time with no
problem whatsoever and doesn't mind a
mass in disorder,
then that's the,
the conscientious person is going to
think that the unconscientious person is
useless and the unconscientious person
is going to think that the conscientious
person is an uptight tyrant.
And that's very,
very hard to overcome.
It's,
it's like a fatal flaw.
So those extreme personality differences
across more than one or two traits is,
is going to make your relationship
extraordinarily difficult.
So the only place where that might be
different is that,
you know,
you probably don't want to both be high
in neuroticism.
So like if one of you is high in
neuroticism and the other isn't,
that's kind of a nice balance because
one of you will be a little alert to
threat and the other one will come.
The one who is alert to threat down.
If you're both low in neuroticism,
well then that's not going to be too
much of a problem.
Although you might be a little bit less
risk averse than you should be.
But mostly you want a fair bit of
similarity in terms of personality.
Then I guess the other thing is is that
well do you have something like a shared
vision of the future?
You know,
like how are you going to mediate the
Chi inevitable conflict between whose
career takes priority and,
and what about kids?
Do you both want kids?
And if you do want kids,
when do you want them and how many do
you want and what's your sense about
who's responsible for what,
when with regards to the kids and the
same when you're running a household,
it's like,
do you have some sense of,
do you have enough shared beliefs?
So that running a household together is
something that is with a peaceful
household and a productive household is
within the realm of possibility.
So I'm [inaudible] that's,
that's,
that's what it looks like to me.
So.
MMM.
That's a lot of things.
So
you said you act as if God exists.
Do you also act as if the devil exists?
Man,
I think I probably act even more as if
the devil exists because it's a lot.
In some sense.
It's a lot more easy for me.
And I think it is for most people.
I'm,
it's easy.
It's easier for me to believe in the
reality of malevolence and evil and to
be terrified about that getting a grip
on me than it is to be optimistic and
naive about the possibility of
transcendent good.
Like it,
it's just that,
it's not that I am skeptical about the
reality of transcendent good.
I mean,
fundamentally I believe that good is
more powerful than evil.
I do believe that.
But there's something palpable about
evil that is,
and it's also undeniable.
It's like,
well,
you can debate about whether or not
heaven exists,
you know,
and you can even be skeptical,
but you can't debate about whether the
Gulag archipelago exists.
And you can't debate about Auschwitz.
And you can't debate about the fact that
people's proclivity towards blindness
and malevolence produced those horrors
and the horrors that people often
encounter in their day to day world and
in their relationships.
So it's very easy for someone like me to
be a believer in evil and to try to turn
away from that.
And so and but,
but through deep contemplation,
you know,
I've come to the conclusion that the
ability of human beings to turn away
from evil and to pursue good is more
powerful malevolence itself.
But that's more of,
it's funny.
That's more of a,
that fills me with,
with hope and,
and and awe I guess is the right word
when I can bring it to mind and think
that we can in fact defeat malevolence
but sort of on a moment to moment basis,
the malevolence is so palpable and so
real that it's a more powerful,
it's a more powerful motivator for,
for avoidance.
I don't mean avoidance of
responsibility,
I mean avoidance of walking down that
path.
And I think that's probably again
keeping with the cycle,
well known psychological doctrine that
people are more loss averse than they
are gained sensitive,
you know,
so a loss of x,
it upsets you more to lose $5 then it
does make you happy to gain $5.
That's,
that's a well known psychological fact.
And it's because we're more sensitive to
punishment and negative emotion.
And that's because while you can die in
agony,
but you can only be so happy.
So yes,
I certainly act as if the devil exists,
I would say,
and I think I probably believed in the
devil,
so to speak,
speaking metaphorically,
before I believed in God,
I became convinced of the reality of
evil and that really,
and not only that,
not only convinced of the reality of
evil,
but also convinced that everyone was
destined to play their part in that
including me,
and that it would be better if I played
the least part in that as possible.
You know?
And that sort of brings us back to this
book.
You know,
a soldier knits and said the line that
divides good from evil runs down the
heart of every individual,
right?
It's an internal thing.
Nada.
It's not between states,
it's not between groups.
It's between elements of our psyche and
our individual responsibility is to
work,
to ameliorate suffering and to constrain
malevolence and to start with ourselves.
And so that's a good place to end.
So thank you all very much for your
continued support,
for paying attention to this q and a for
everything that you've offered to me
over the last few years.
It's been an absolutely overwhelming
experience,
for example,
to go out and do these lectures.
They're unbelievably positive
experiences.
To See all these thousands of people
come out to engage in a serious
discussion about vision and strategy and
responsibility and individual
sovereignty and the,
the possibility that we could all aim
together acting individually towards at
least a less hellish future.
That's really something.
So,
um,
that's good guys.
So
till next time,
till November,
and I'll put out this video on the
soldier knits and preface,
I'll put that out before November 1st.
That'll probably be next on the next on
the list.
And so it's off to Europe and,
uh,
we'll talk to you all soon.
Thanks very much.
Bye for now.